there was a period where you left Sarah
alive right yeah but you were really
nice cuz we're you I was on an NBC and
you would still do my show you're so
nice about it well come on and you would
do my show in the early early days when
when hardly anybody else would do the
show but you were maybe it was maybe a
little strange was he when NBC at the
floor yeah I got fired right and you got
fired from I got fired from Saturday
Night Live and then that summer I loved
doing your show but the and and NBC my
manager call batma said NBC wants you to
do Conan it sweeps and I said what do
you mean and he goes it's sweeps week so
good they want to want you on there and
I said I thought they don't like me they
just fired me he's like no no no it's
for Conan though it's not Saturday Night
Live I was like but isn't that NBC and
he was like yeah I go and to make like a
big stand that I was young and I was
angry I said will you tell them I will
do Conan show but they have to buy me a
fax machine why a fax machine I really
like I talked to my I think it was Gus
like a week earlier I asked my brother I
go everybody's got these fax machines
man can I get one he goes they're like
400 bucks and I went whoa no let's wait
on that man let's wait on that but
eventually I want to get one an effects
machine then this came along and I was
like there it is baby
best man did you ever use it I wasn't
great at it
you